una multitud de padres furiosos en esta
escuela de niñas en Teherán su ira es
provocada por lo que parecen ser más
envenenamientos por aerosol en tres
escuelas de niñas en la ciudad en la
ciudad de ardeville una escena similar
siete escuelas exclusivamente femeninas
fueron atacadas los medios de
comunicación iraníes informan que más de
100 estudiantes fueron hospitalizadas el
miércoles la mayoría con afecciones
respiratorias
en los últimos meses unas 800
estudiantes de todo el país han sido
envenenadas en la escuela Aunque ninguna
de ellas Ha fallecido los primeros casos
se registraron en la ciudad Santa de kom
a finales de noviembre
Mira a mi hija no siente las piernas
incluso cuando se las pellizco no siente
nada no puede respirar no envíen a sus
hijas a la escuela a principios de esta
semana el viceministro de asuntos
exteriores de Irán insistió en que los
informes de envenenamiento eran
exagerados parte de una guerra
psicológica dirigida por medios de
comunicación hostiles y ante la
creciente preocupación pública el
presidente
ordenó una investigación oficial pero
tras meses de violenta represión de un
movimiento de protesta desencadenado por
la muerte de una joven bajo custodia de
la policía de la moral el pasado mes de
septiembre la confianza pública está en
un punto crítico
la confianza del pueblo iraní en la
autoridad está Quizá en su punto más
bajo la gente sufre económica y
emocionalmente en el fondo no hay
transparencia no hay credibilidad y no
hay rendición de cuentas
algunos iraníes sospechan que los
envenenamientos los llevan a cabo
religiosos de línea dura que intentan
impedir que las niñas vayan a la escuela
otros temen represalias o ficiales por
la participación femenina en el
movimiento protesta que ha durado ya
varios meses